all right The Hobbit is sneaking up on
us faster and faster every day so we got
to talk about Lord of the Rings however
if I don't successfully convey how epic
Lord of the Rings is in the course of
talking about these movies I will
consider it a personal failure upon
myself just saying that being said let's
talk about some epic business the Lord
of the Rings the Fellowship of the Ring
so the Lord of the Rings trilogy is
directed by Peter Jackson based off of
the beloved fantasy books by JRR Tolkien
and warning to you guys I'm going to
talk about this movie with spoilers in
it so if you haven't seen Lord of the
Rings yet the short answer is go see it
now for the sake of all things holy so
the Lord of the Rings starts out with a
really cool recap in middle-earth
history as to what has happened thus far
concerning the ring you see a sweet war
with elves and people fighting Sarang
Sauron is this big evil he was defeated
3000 years ago by his seal door and he
made this ring he poured in all of his
malice and contempt for life so since
the ring survived
Sauron soul isn't gone he's not really
dead I mean he's dead for the most part
but he's still have been gaining power
now we're at the moment where Sauron is
gonna make a big move to take over
middle-earth again and this ring has
been in the lap of Bilbo Baggins for the
past like 50 years they can't wait to
see that happen in The Hobbit it's gonna
be badass I love when you see the
hobbits and Bilbo and Gandalf talking
with Frodo you know you really get the
Hobbit lifestyle hobbits they're not
exciting people they're pretty content
they just want to drink smoke weed and
eat that is a hobbits life so when all
this drama is happening out there in the
world they're like I really want nothing
to do with that
that's right drama free fun-loving
people those are my people much as I
would love to say that I would probably
be a wizard and Lord of the Rings or a
badass warrior I would probably be a
hobbit who wouldn't want that life again
Dolph sees this ring and he's like
something about this ring I don't like
dude Gandalf is the grey wizard played
by Ian McKellen who completely kills it
in this movie which is funny when I
first met my best friend like back in
the day when Lord of the Rings came out
in theatres or was coming out in
theaters I was like oh yeah magneto play
some wizard in the movie my now friend
then was just a guy I'd never met before
in my life he was like come all right
excuse me some wizard know the wizard I
was like who are you but he had my
respect I'll tell you that
story short Gandalf can't handle this
ring at all because this ring is
actually it's it's an evil entity it's
alive it has a will of its own and I
love when they convey that I love when
they say things like the ring found this
person when Gandalf's talking with Frodo
he's like you have to remember the ring
wants to get back to his master it wants
to be found sweet I need to haul this
thing around that pretty much would blow
the whistle and call the evil nazgul at
me at any given time perfect we're
drama-free people hobbits you know that
right those nazgûl are just badass so
pretty much the Wraith version of
terminator but there are nine of them
and they are coming after this ring and
they will slaughter anyone to get to it
and they will kill the one who has it
he's here that evil screeching yell
you're like yeah your own bad shapes bad
news for you but halfway through this
movie you don't even have the fellowship
yet you're just appreciating the
build-up usually a long build-up makes a
movie kind of seem like a grind to me
I'm like alright come on let's just get
to really cool [ __ ] but this movie has
cool enough stuff among really good
character development and it has
excitement with the nazgûl chasing Frodo
so you're like yeah this movie speaking
to me then they get to Rivendell where
the elf Elrond he's like okay this ring
has to do with all races of middle-earth
so you all have to decide what to do and
no matter what they decide there's only
one thing they can do with this ring the
ring is indestructible except for one
way you have to take this ring to Mount
Doom which is in Mordor in the lion's
den of evil drop it into the volcano
where it was created it's the only way
to destroy this ring yeah this ring that
wants to be found you take it into its
masters territory to destroy it yeah
screw that noise the special extended
edition has this scene grab or Emir he's
one of the humans he's like why not just
use the ring against the enemy which
would seem like a good idea and I
thought when I saw him say that in the
trailer I was like yeah why not I agree
with that dude Boromir this movie really
does a good job at conveying no that's
not a good idea
idiots do that and Gandalf just stands
up and starts speaking the language of
Mordor in the elf City and all the
clouds go down all the elves are like I
love that scene he's like I'm not gonna
apologize for that if you do that that
language will be everywhere so really
think it through douche but then the
Fellowship is formed and now Frodo needs
to take this ring to Mordor to Mount
Doom and he has a fellowship of a bunch
of people to help him he's got his three
Hobbit friends he's got Gandalf the
wizard Gimli the dwarf Legolas the elf
Boromir a human warrior and he's got
Aragorn Aragorn is a really key piece to
Lord of the Rings like if they got a
[ __ ] actor to play Aragorn if he didn't
empathize with him if you didn't connect
with him this whole thing really where
crumble he'd be like oh yeah the whole
Frodo thing's cool but Aragorn luckily
Viggo Mortensen kills it as Aragorn why
it's important is because Aragorn is
destined to be the king he's gonna be
the king of men he's gonna be the one
that unites men together and he walked
away from all that because he's like I
want nothing to do with it my ancestor
who held that ring just didn't destroy
it and held on to it because they
thought it would be awesome now look at
the boat we're in I guess I love really
badass really efficient damaged
characters who walked away from their
destiny who are now kind of being like
oh yeah it probably would be a good idea
if I step up to this this movie has
great cinematography too you see those
swooping shots you know the scenery I
mean they're a dime a dozen now back
when Lord of the Rings came out it was
the movie that hit it and hit it on the
screen with a vengeance when I see these
really epic swooping shots of soldiers
going down hills to meet an army to
clash I'm like oh that's a Lord of the
Rings shot the Moria scenes badass too I
mean more is this underground mine it's
pretty much been sacked by goblins all
the dwarves and there are dead but they
get into this big scrap in the mines of
Moria and there's this big cave troll
which you know what that's why it's a
bummer that YouTube did not exist in
middle-earth because YouTube would have
taught them you don't fight the troll
with magic or swords or axes or bows and
arrows or anything like that you just
ignore the trolls and they will go away
just survival tactic it's just it's
timeless it is what it is today they
hold their own but then you see it you
see the Balrog of Morgoth and Gandalf
like yep this thing's beyond any of you
just run and they just haul ass and the
music's great it's all kicking on and
then he stands toe-to-toe with that
Balrog this thing's enormous the big
flaming demon with horns he's like you
got buzz and you're like holy [ __ ] old
dude you're more badass than anything
I've ever seen you think anyone else
would have done that you think Darth
Vader would stand toe-to-toe with a
Balrog of Morgoth no he would not granny
he does follow through the shadow and
thus for the rest of the movie you
assume him dead but this is Lord of the
Rings not all things are what they seem
but doesn't change the fact that at the
time that I saw Lord of the Rings I was
like whoa Gandalf get boba fett it no he
didn't I'm saying right now he did not
but that music kicks on man never was
like no it's all slo-mo it's rough
to touch on the music at this point
Howard Shores music the musical score in
this movie is beyond epic it's that
music that you hear and you're
immediately taken back to middle-earth
and you're like yeah that's why I love
this I went on the hobbit website just
today and you hear the Hobbit music and
you're like I just loved the themes of
Lord of the Rings it has everything to
do with friendship and honor loyalty
sacrifice I love that Elrond told The
Fellowship he was like all right the
ring bearers promised to do this but the
rest of you the support crew the
fellowship there's been no oath given no
blood oath taken that makes you have to
go farther than you think you need to go
no one is obligated to follow Frodo to
the end into the heart of the enemy to
Mount Doom and probably death what they
would do it why friendship but I really
got to tip my hat to Boromir in this
movie the ring is a really seductive
thing it makes guys feel empowered
they'll do anything for it minutes
treacherous little betray him it's like
the vagina of middle-earth it will
corrupt anybody who's around it for long
enough it's not like oh if the ring does
corrupt me it's more like when the ring
does corrupt me in the Fellowship
Boromir was the one who was most
susceptible to the Rings he was the one
who fell first he tried to take it from
Frodo he tried to kill him but he
realized what he was doing and he gave
his life for the hobbits like big-time
took arrows into the chest he's just
fighting everyone off with a sword
you're like yeah you're you're awesome
your dad's a dick we'll touch on that
later but you Boromir you're not so bad
ultimately I'm glad everything worked
out for the Lord of the Rings movies
there was a time where Lord of the Rings
was gonna be two movies the whole law
Florian scene wasn't gonna be in it God
knows the nerf bat version of Lord of
the Rings we would have gotten Peter
Jackson was proving himself in
production so they were like yeah okay
three movies and now we have a trilogy
which is just it's not even a movie
trilogy it's an experience a religion to
some you sit down with the special
extended editions of Lord of the Rings
you just take 12 hours out of your day
just to watch them all back-to-back it
does such a good job at putting you in
to middle-earth you're there you're
invested you love the characters you're
going on the class nothing else needs to
be said I can't actually convey to you
guys how happy I get when I watch The
Lord of the Rings is one of those things
where I will go months without watching
it and I'll see the Lord of the Rings
blu-rays that I have and I'm like I
should probably watch that again then I
watch them and I'm like why don't I
watch this day in day out every day
that's just how I am with Lord of the
Ring
why simple Lord of the Rings the
Fellowship of the Ring is awesome
tacular the world of Lord of the Rings
in middle-earth is just such an involved
entity and that credit goes to j.r.r
tolkien he made that world he made an
Elvis language a fake language that's
just it's crazy but the credit for
capturing that depth and all those
layers that made middle-earth
middle-earth in the movie for the big
screen that goes to Peter Jackson right
so have you seen the Lord of the Rings
movies have you seen the Fellowship of
the Ring what did you think about it
comment below let me know we're gonna do
the whole trilogy before the hobbits out
trust me I got you covered and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more